hi everyone i'm mirabelle a customer
engineer at google cloud
welcome back to the google cloud
technical guides for startups where we
are creating a series of videos for
technical enablement to help startups to
start build and grow their businesses
successfully and sustainably on google
cloud
in our previous video we covered the
google for startups cloud program
today we will be moving on to our third
topic on firestore
we will be covering an overview of
google cloud's databases portfolio deep
dive into firestore run through a demo
explore a sample architecture and a case
study and we will wrap up with some
actions that you can take to learn more
about firestore
let's get started with an overview of
google cloud's managed database service
offerings
there is a full suite of different
database services available to meet your
different needs ranging from in-memory
to non-relational and relational
databases as well as the data warehouse
offering
today we will be focusing on firestore
our scalable serverless document store
when you create an application there are
many factors that go into its
development
the complete ecosystem for application
development could include the core ui
frameworks and operating systems to
build the application
in-app services from firebase for
features like authentication
and back-end services from google cloud
to manage aspects like analytics using
bigquery
firestore brings together these
different parts in an intelligent way by
integrating with each of these
portfolios
the mission of firestore is to unlock
application innovation with simplicity
speed and confidence
firestore's rich history started as a
document database after all nearly every
important application needs to store
data
however real-time storing and exchanging
data between clients and servers have
historically been complex
even more challenging is caching data
for applications on device to manage
hiccups in terms of transient network
connectivity
firestore aims to address these concerns
with a full back-end as a service
so what are some benefits that firestar
provides
first you can focus on your business
value
firestore provides a back-end as a
service for fast application development
there are features for real-time
applications and offline mode and you
can run with confidence on serverless
the firestore data model supports
flexible hierarchical data structures
store your data in documents which are
organized into collections
collections enable similar documents to
be queried together
sub-collections are also supported
allowing a collection to be a child of a
document so that related data can be
stored together in hierarchies
this structure enables queries across
all similarly named collections
firestore has built in live
synchronization and offline mode
real-time updates are possible because
firestore uses data synchronization to
update data on any connected device
for offline support firestore caches
data that your application is actively
using so that the application can
continue to read write listen to or
query the data even if the device is
applied
when the device comes back online
firestore synchronizes any local changes
back to the database
these features make it easy to build
multi-user collaborative applications
for mobile web and iot devices including
workflows like activity tracking
real-time analytics social user profiles
and gaming leaderboards
in firestore we can use queries to
retrieve documents
these queries can include multiple chain
filters and combine filtering and
sorting
firestore indexes by default and for
most queries the query performance is
proportional to the size of the result
set not your data set
furthermore firestore allows you to run
sophisticated asset transactions against
your document data giving you the
flexibility in the way that you
structure your data firestorm provides
automatic multi-region data replication
strong consistency atomic batch
operations and real transaction support
with automatic multi-region replication
and strong consistency your data is more
secure and has a 99.999
availability guarantee
firestore also scales up automatically
with no downtime
this scaling mechanism lets firestore to
serve thousands of requests per second
and millions of concurrent connections
you pay only for your actual usage based
on the storage size and the number of
operations
firestore supports libraries for popular
languages
focus on your application development
using firestore client-side development
libraries for web ios android flasher c
plus plus and unity
firestore also supports server side
development libraries using node.js java
go ruby and php
let's see how all that works in practice
through a demo
here we are going to build a restaurant
recommendation web application powered
by firestore
we will be using the web client library
in this demo
we will be going through how to set up a
firestore database write data to the
database display data on the application
and also how to secure the data
our restaurant recommendation
application uses firestore to save and
receive restaurant information and
ratings
to enable firestore we can go to the
firebase console's build section click
firestore database and then click create
database
access to data in firestore is
controlled by security rules
we will talk more about this later but
for now let's start in test mode which
leaves the data open by default for
quick setup next we select a location
for our data this location cannot be
changed later on
once we have selected a location click
enable to provision the firestore
database
now we have our database set up but
there is still no data so our
application is still empty
let's write some data to firestore so
that we can populate the applications ui
this can be done manually by the
firebase console for example by clicking
on start collection here another option
to write data to firestore is from the
application itself true basic firestore
right so let's head over to our code
the main model object in our application
is a restaurant so let's write some code
that adds a restaurant document to
restaurants collection
this code adds a new document to the
restaurants collection by first getting
a reference to the firestore collection
and then adding the data now let's test
it out
by clicking on admob data on the
application it will automatically
generate a random set of restaurant
objects
and then it will call the add restaurant
function that we have just written to
add this data to firestore
there is still no data in the app yet
but that is because we still need to
implement retrieving the data which is
our next step
if we navigate to the firestore tab in
the firebase console we see that there
are new documents in the restaurants
collection
the next step is to retrieve this data
from firestore and displayed in our app
so let's head back to our code
the two key steps that we'll be doing
here are to create the query and to add
a snapshot listener
first let's construct a query that will
serve the default unfiltered list of
restaurants
in this code we are constructing a query
that will retrieve up to 50 restaurants
from the top level collection called
restaurants
these restaurants are ordered by average
waiting
after declaring the query it will be
passed to the getdocument's inquiry
method which is responsible for loading
and rendering the data
that's the next code that we'll be
writing and this is where the snapshot
listener comes in
in this code query.on snapshot will
trigger its callback every time the
result of the query changes
the first time the callback is triggered
with the entire result set of the query
meaning the whole restaurant's
collection on firestore
after that when a document is deleted
that is when change.type equals to
removed we call a function that removes
the restaurant from the ui
as the list of restaurants changes the
listener will keep updating
automatically and the changes show up on
the site almost immediately
now that we have implemented both
changes let's head back to the app and
verify that the restaurants that we have
just added are visible there
at the beginning of this demo we set up
our security rules to completely open
the database to any reads or writes
in a real application we would want to
set more fine-grained rules to prevent
undesirable data access or modification
this can be done under the rules tab on
the firestore interface
here we can edit our security rules to
restrict access to ensure that clients
can only make safe changes
our first rule will apply to the
restaurant's collection
for example an authenticated user can
read write and update a restaurant
document
however updates for restaurant document
can only change its rating and not the
name or any other immutable data
in this case the leads are not allowed
which is the default setting
we can also apply rules for other
collections such as the ratings
collection
here an authenticated user can read
their ratings but ratings can only be
created if the user id matches the sign
in user to prevent spoofing
deletes and updates are not allowed
let's publish the changes so that they
take effect
and with that we have learned how to set
up a firestore database how to perform
reads and writes and how to secure data
access using security rules now that we
have an idea of how firestore works
where would it fit in a wider
architecture
let's dig deeper into the use case for a
retail platform providing
recommendations to its users
this architecture diagram was created
using our architecture diagramming tool
if you're interested in making your own
diagrams check out the link in the
description box below
now back to the architecture itself
here we have buyers through different
mediums both online and offline
a web application records live data
points about online users such as their
geographic region and their device type
and then writes the collected data to
firestore
but we do not just stop there we carry
on to obtain insights from this data
each new record creation in firestore
triggers a data pipeline in cloud
functions that copies the data over to
bigquery
a recommendation engine implemented
using spark mlib and deployed on
dataproc is then trained using this live
user data in bigquery and with product
metadata stored in cloud sql
this recommendation engine then provides
predictions for recommended products
real-time predictions are written to
firestore and then automatically pushed
to the online user devices
batch predictions can be shared with
offline users through an email service
and if you wanted to see a real-life
example here is a customer case study
paired pay is a fintech startup offering
solutions for paying at the table taking
out order payment viewing digital menus
creating orders and card processing
pair pay uses firebase's real-time
client libraries and firestore to allow
guests sitting around a table to see
each other selecting their menu items
for payment and to settle up instantly
by also using data studio and bigquery
purple enables restaurants to tap the
vast amounts of data in firestore in
near real time to easily visualize
results and to make adjustments to their
operations on the fly
how has this helped the real-time
capabilities of firebase and firestore
has sped up table turns by an average of
15 minutes relieving stress for guests
and a time sink for the restaurant
with that we have come to the end of
today's video all in all we have covered
an overview of google cloud's databases
portfolio we dived into firestore and
saw a demo sample architecture as well
as a case study
for those who are keen to learn more
about firestore please refer to the
links in the description box to get
additional resources
in our next episode you will be learning
about bigquery you will get an overview
of bigquery how to build etl data
pipelines understand more about bigquery
pricing and optimization data governance
and bigquery ml
and that's a wrap don't forget to like
and subscribe to our youtube channel and
click on the bell icon to get notified
each time a new video is posted
thank you and stay tuned for our next
video
[Music]